well in in a perfect world I would never
collaborate with anyone because I'm a
megalomaniac and I would love to be able
to just be completely autonomous and do
everything by myself but the problem is
I'm not such a good singer so if I want
to have good vocals on my record I
either have to work with good singers or
sample old vocals I mean I wish I could
sing like bono or David Bowie and then I
would just stay in my studio never have
to interact with real people but
unfortunately you know as I said if I
want to have good vocals on the record i
have to work with vocalist
well I mean at this point I've worked
with so many different musicians and so
many different vocalists and I haven't I
don't know if I've had any disasters I
mean it can be uncomfortable when you
you know you're working with someone
you've never worked with before they
come into the studio and it's clear from
the get-go that it's not working out you
know I mean I guess it's the equivalent
of being set up on a blind date and like
in the first 30 seconds you know that
it's not working out but how do you
politely excuse yourself but in this
case there in your home there in your
studio and and then I just try them like
if someone's not very good at doing one
thing I try and maybe push them in a
different direction or try and get
something that I can salvage in the
future
my biggest my biggest strength as a
musician hmm I can't pick one thing I
mean the answer that sort of if I didn't
stop to think about it the answer that
would have come out was that I guess my
biggest strength is a musician is very
simply how much I love music you know
how I mean I've been making music for 30
years and it's still more than any other
art form can affect me so powerfully and
so emotionally so I guess that's my
biggest strength is that very simply I
just really love the media in which I
work run medium in which i work and i
love how it affects me emotionally